cassidy hutchinson was at the heart of
the trump white house the principal aide
to donald trump's chief of staff the
witness will please stand and raise her
right hand
the hearing was unscheduled and the
speculation over what she might say huge
the president
was
extremely angry
at
the attorney general's ap interview
and had thrown his lunch against the
wall
you can see a map of the first floor
of the west wing from the perspective of
an insider with a desk just yards from
the oval office she described a volatile
president in the days around the
storming of the u.s capitol that morning
on january the 6th 2021 mr trump
prepared to address his supporters he
was told some in the crowd were armed
but didn't care and wanted the magnetic
security screens to be removed i
overheard the president say something to
the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing mags away
let my people in they can march the
capital from here pre-recorded and live
testimony as the committee seeks to
prove that the former president knew an
armed mob was bent on violence and to
prove that all this was the culmination
of his plan to overturn the election
result listen to this about the moment
the secret service deemed it too
dangerous for the president to go to the
capitol the president said something to
the effect of
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr angle grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle
up at the capitol they were calling for
the vice president to be hanged he had
defied trump and recognized joe biden as
president now we know the conversations
in the west wing i remember pat saying
something to the effect of
mark we need to do something more
they're literally calling
for the vice president to be effing hung
and mark had responded something to the
effect of
you heard him pat he thinks mike
deserves it he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong
days of evidence many revelations but an
indifferent american public will today
delivered quite some punch